with the ever-changing world that we
live in right now renovations are
becoming more and more common in the
architecture industry
that's why today i wanted to show you
exactly how to use renovation filters
what's going on guys my name is david
thomas and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk all things
architecture and technology if that's
something that interests you make sure
you smash that subscribe button down
below
because today we're talking archicad 24
and we're talking renovation
layers there are a magnitude of
different ways we can use renovation
layers
and today i'm just simply going to show
you how i personally use them
in the real world that might be able to
help you and benefit you in your own
career
if you are struggling with architecture
or struggling to get motivated in any
way shape or form
check out the links down below i've got
all sorts of cool stuff
like a discord chat that you can join or
even checklists for your working
drawings and construction drawings
to make you a much better architect or a
future architect
and i genuinely just try to help you
guys as much out in the links down below
so check them out and let's get started
with today's video okay so as arcade 24
loads up on my screen i wanted to
continue testing out this
side-by-side format in most of my other
tutorials i've been a little floating
head somewhere down here on the screen
however i like to be a little bit more
interactive with you guys as much as
possible
so let me know down in the comments down
below if you prefer
this sort of side-by-side technique or
if you prefer the floating head i know
the comments in the last video were
predominantly
floating ahead so i'm really interested
to know your comments
now with that being said let's get into
arcade 24.
okay so i've got arcade 24 open and i'm
just going to go for the standard
australian template
i'm not going to throw any random
templates at you guys you can follow
along with this
at home however you like okay so with
arcad 24 open
we're going to see this renovation
filters panel down the bottom here if
you don't see this panel
just come up to window at the top scroll
down to palettes
and look for renovation if i untick that
you'll see that palette down the bottom
disappears completely so if we go back
into window
palette and scroll back up to renovation
clicking that on we see we have no
filters applied at the current moment
so basically what renovation filters do
is they make your project a lot easier
to manage especially if it's existing
going demolished going to brand new
there's a very simple way to set it up
and i'll show you the quickest way but
i'll also go into depth in all the
settings in this video
so we'll start by the absolute quickest
and easiest way to use demolition
filters
so if we go into a wall tool for example
i'm not going to teach layers or tools
or anything
i'm just going to simply draw three
boxes of walls so
there's one we're going to copy that
across
there's two and there's three so we have
our three walls
right in the middle of our project and
if i highlight one of them
it's going to say it's a new status so
what i'm going to start by
doing is highlighting all three of them
and going new
status now because no filter has been
applied whatsoever
we're not going to notice any changes
but if we start going through these
renovation filters and layers so if we
click on existing
you'll see the color for example changes
if we go to demolition
nothing happens because we're not
demolishing anything but if i was to
select this middle one
and then click demolish you'd see it
changed to a dashed red line because
that's how the settings are by default
if we continue to work our way through
this list we go to after demolition
you'll see
that is completely gone then we can move
continuously forward to new construction
new construction grays out all the
existing buildings
and does something very different to the
new buildings so if i highlight and
select
all of this last square that we created
and go new status
you'll see that it changes its
appearance so if you were to go out and
produce a set of documentation with
existing drawings you'd have a multitude
of different plans
we'd start with an existing ground floor
plan we then go to a demolition ground
floor plan
it's up to you if you include an after
demolition plan to make sure it's clean
and visible
or if you just jump straight into a new
construction plan like you see
here it's important that people have all
this information
you don't just jump straight ahead to
new construction
now there is a couple more filters in
here like planning development
and also no filters applied and we go
back to our original state
all of these can be customized to
however you see fit and however you
operate your business now having said
that there's a number of ways to change
these settings to make it look like
exactly how we need it to so new
construction is one of my personal
favorites because it shows you the
grayed out
line of all the existing buildings and
shows you new in color so you can
clearly differentiate what the
difference is
but if we wanted to chop and change
things around to make it work for us
specifically we'd come down into
renovation
filter options so i'm actually not sure
if that's popping up on my screen
let me make my window a little bit
smaller here
there we go so you can see renovation
filter options
all the way at the bottom of my screen
so if i was to click on that
i'll drag my box out to full size again
if i'm to click on that renovation
filter options we'd have
this palette open up in front of us now
as we click through
these settings here on the top left hand
corner you're going to see
the floor plan preview change exactly
like we just showcased a second ago
so as we click through it it shows you
exactly what's going on
so we can change this and chop and
change it as much as we like and mess
with it as much as we like
to show exactly what we want to show so
for instance if we wanted to change this
existing into a completely different
color
we could go to graphic overwrite rules
and click on graphic override rules
to open up a secondary palette inside
the secondary palette you have the
three main characteristics at the top
and then you have a series of additional
layers that can change graphic override
rules now that's something we can go
into to creating wall types and all
sorts of different good stuff
but for the time being we won't talk too
much about these down the bottom we're
just going to focus on the top three
layers so we're talking about existing
settings here and existing elements so
the default on here
is all of these settings here which i
haven't changed from template
personally speaking i do like to use the
gray but i don't like
to preference all the line types to turn
to solid
sometimes you need the dashed lines to
clearly indicate what things
are so in my personal experience i
usually untick line type
keep line marker on and untick
everything else
in that palette so we're just changing
all the blacks blues greens to grays
we can go through and change the
different gray color that we might
prefer
there might be a part of you that wants
oranges existing or blue is existing i
don't know why
the industry accepted standard is grey
here in australia but around the world
it's completely different and
everybody has different preferences so
don't take my grey as hearsay and don't
take the grey as it's got to be grey
learn what it is in your country and
adopt to those standards
but in this instance we're going to
stick to grey just for the purposes of
argument so we'll click
62 and we'll click ok
if i continue to go back to my overwrite
rules and just click
ok and change it to new construction
we'll see that it's
just grayed out we haven't actually
completely diminished the walls and
taken out all the patterns
and especially if you've got hatching in
the middle of the walls to indicate
some sort of insulation it isn't
dissipated completely with just blanked
out gray bits
this is completely up to you guys how
you manage these settings
but we'll continue to work through them
just so i can give you more information
on them
if we come back to existing and go back
to our overwrite settings
that is my preference of setting up
existing layers
now inside the filter settings you're
also going to see this section here
it's applicable to every single category
inside the renovation filters
and the principles are exactly the same
so basically in the filter settings you
can have your existing elements
showing up exactly as the default
settings are you can
hide all of your existing settings or
you can override them with the graphic
override rules
so for instance if we were back here and
i changed this
to orange and then clicked okay you'd
see as an
override setting everything went orange
but if i ticked it back to show
it'd go back to the original settings
that we had before the override graphic
rules are just the simplest and easiest
and also the quickest way to change
everything at once but it does mess with
you if you have a magnitude of different
elements and
structural components that you're trying
to achieve with these renovation filters
i found personally from experience that
the override graphic rules work a tree
if they're done correctly and if the job
isn't too complex
so to provide you with a secondary
example if we move to our demolition
layer
and we look into this preview box over
here we'll see that
everything is dashed red now looking
into the graphic
override rules and clicking on
everything to be demolished
we'll see that it changes all the line
types dashed which is fantastic we like
that
it changes all the lines to red again
fantastic we like that
white fill background so it's clear and
it continues to change
all the fill pens as well so if you have
a floor hatch
it goes red if you have a surface it
goes red so you can see it in 3d as well
these settings are actually really
really good and i don't have a tendency
to change them whatsoever for demolition
red dash lines are in my opinion at
least a universally accepted
demolition layout structure so if you do
like demolition to be clean recognizable
most places around the world
feel free to correct me if i'm wrong but
red dash lines
usually means knock it out the same way
we change
that orange on the existing layer we can
come in here and change it to blue for
instance
if for example blue is the accepted
color in your country and just click
ok and again we'll see all of those
elements
change to blue now if we went back into
our
filter settings and went show we would
see them just as if they appeared
normally there'd be nothing gone
and a demolition layout would kind of
become redundant if we went hide
again it would become redundant because
we have our after demolition layout
but then our override rules really get
us where we need to be
so if i come back into my graphic
override rules and
change that all back to red i can't
remember which red it was i think it was
number 20
and click ok we have our
red back in action now this is of course
applicable to all the categories and all
the renovation filters up the top here
even if we move into new construction we
see that we overrid
our existing elements and their orange
so let's go back into graphic overrides
existing elements change that back to a
nice gray
61 what it was originally and we'll see
everything's lightly grayed out we know
exactly what it is
our filter settings are overriding those
settings
our demolition is hidden completely we
don't need to see that
for any instance if you needed to see it
you could change it
you could hide it you could override it
depending how you want to showcase your
drawings
you have all these options at the click
of a button now obviously we go back to
hide it's a new construction
drawing so we don't want to see anything
but the
benefit and the biggest benefit in my
opinion of renovation layers is you
don't need
to worry about making errors and making
mistakes or if something changes in an
existing drawing
you don't have to go back and figure it
out change it and then go back to the
new construction
it was a very long time in my career
that we didn't use renovation filters
and having moved to renovation filters
it is an
absolute game changer now with a quick
little interlude i wanted to shout out
cuts clothing today they are an
incredible brand that i've been working
with for over a year now
and they just genuinely make the best
most comfortable t-shirts in the game
i wouldn't recommend them on this
channel if i thought they were garbage
you can go back through my channel for
years and years and years and almost
every single black shirt that i've ever
worn has been by cuts
so take a look at them there is a link
down below if you want to check them out
it would be greatly appreciated now
finally in this renovation settings
palette you're going to see
this little dialog box down the bottom
which has a series of different options
and depending on which renovation filter
you're on
different things are going to be enabled
and disabled
now we can go through these and change
them again to see
and suit how we like our documentation
so you can see on existing they've
hidden
all the opening dimension markers if i
untick it
you'll see all the dimension markers pop
up so they're more so labels for your
doors and your windows
if i tick it again they hide the solid
cut feel is a very
promising one and a very good one to use
on existing if i
untick it you'll see all those internal
skins
open up again so if i re-tick that we
can see
it's gone back to gray now for example
if we come to our new construction
that isn't grayed out and if we wanted
to continue that theme
showing all those walls as gray or
potentially white or whatever we had in
mind
and we didn't want to show that as just
a textured wall
because we didn't know what was inside
we didn't know if it was brick if it was
concrete
if it was timber we could simply just
click that box and hide it all
so in an instance where you weren't
entirely sure what that material was
made out of
or if it was a 500 600 deep wall that
you had
no way of accessing internally you could
hide all the materiality
and all the internal information of a
wall on a construction drawing
simply by clicking one layer and not
having to go in
and do an abundance of 2d work so moving
down to these elements to be demolished
now on our existing renovation filters
layer
what you'll see is if for example we
unticked hide all
dimension markers and did the same on
demolition layers requirements all
of our wall tags and window tags so door
tags and window tags would show up
because a series of these doors have
already been clicked to demolished
those tags could be hidden now on an
existing plan
personally i'd like to see every single
door and window tag
shown because i don't yet know that
information about the windows and the
doors being demolished
so i would untick that personally and
i'd have that more so
hidden in my demolition layer you don't
need to
show this information we just straight
up know they're getting demolished
if you wanted to you can show that on
your demolition layer as well
so you know what doors are getting
demolished it's not critical information
it could be critical information
depending on the job so
really just use this as a guide to help
you understand renovation filters as
best as possible
continuing on down this list we have
high doors windows skylights opening
symbols if we tick that
it literally gets rid of all our doors
windows
and skylights now that might be
something that interests you it might
not be
but in most cases you'd usually like to
see everything that's getting
demolished and everything that's
existing so it's good to have that
unticked
if for example when you came to your
demolition layer you didn't want to see
all your 2d hatching or all your zones
because it was just too messy and too
clunky you could simply tick
hide zones and hide all of that
information
you could simply put a little keynote
all floor coverings to be demolished
adjoining surfaces to be made good
you could do whatever you needed to to
clean that up and make it a
less clunky less messy drawing overall
that looks very clean to me but at the
same time i like to know i'm demolishing
tiles so
that one stays off in my personal
opinion moving further down the track
you can see that we have hide objects
very self-explanatory takes away all the
object we have solid cut feel which then
is basically the same premise as what we
had originally at the top for solid
colored fill for existing elements
it just makes everything extremely
visible but also wastes a lot of ink
so up to you it's a personal preference
transparent film
can again be unticked and ticked very
similar to how zone works depending if
you're working on a
2d element or a zone material the do not
intersect tab
is again not that really critical it
just
intersects walls or doesn't intersect
walls it shows you how much to cut or
don't not
cut it's a personal preference but it
can be ticked on and off like you'd
usually do
now the remaining two here are just very
simple
personal choices in how you document if
you want to mark opens with an x
it just gets really messy it gets really
clunky it gets a little bit too much in
my opinion
so you want to still keep it as clean as
possible and finally your annotated
elements down the bottom
do not override dimensions and text
which is a great one if you don't want
to get rid of all your text if you don't
want your text to go red
if you don't want your labels to go red
you just keep it ticked
and if you do not override drafting
fills and lines again is a separate
option for you as well like i mentioned
previously all of these options can be
adjusted
individually depending on the renovation
filter
so depending on the renovation filter
you're on depending on what information
you want to show
the existing floor plan for example we
could hide all of our markers we could
hide all of our demolition markers
we could hide all of our doors we could
hide all of
our zones and make it a very very very
clean
crisp plan but then how is it existing
we don't see all the existing doors we
don't see the tiles
we have no idea what's going on so
something along
these lines would be a lot better used
and a lot better utilized
for people on site to understand what's
going on for demolition it works very
much the same
i personally like the default settings
they have down here
most of the time the only thing i'd
untick is the annotation elements
sometimes i like the text to go red so
we know we're demolishing text
as well but overall it is a very good
setup there isn't too many things you
need to change
the after demolition plan i personally
don't use that much
it is a clean plan that shows you what's
been demolished and it's probably better
for
during working out stages and actually
using an archicad
then producing an after demolition plan
to submit for a building permit
it might be a mandatory requirement in
your state in your country wherever you
might be
however i don't see too much value in it
personally
but it is there and it's definitely
useful some
for some people that might need that
information finally new construction
is of course the most important it's the
things that
we can clearly differentiate between the
old and the new
and we know exactly where those old
things have gone
simply by flicking through those pages i
personally don't show
any of the information from the
demolition plan so for example if we
would override
and show everything demolished on one
plan it would be very messy it would be
very
clunky and hard to read so we simply
hide everything demolished in my opinion
at least
now in this instance the new
construction if we come back into our
graphic override elements we go
new elements we can see that the
foreground pen is green
we don't want that and we also probably
don't want our surfaces to be
overwritten
if you're doing a new construction model
you're probably showcasing some
materiality in 3d
you're probably showcasing what that
building really needs to look like
so you don't want those surfaces to be
completely overwritten by unticking that
box you
have that freedom and that liberty to
actually change materials as you see fit
if you're doing a 3d massing model for
example and you just want simple shapes
and colors
that is a very quick and easy way to
adjust all of your new construction
surfaces
without having to go change everything
individually then changing it all back
personally i'd go into existing
elements as well and untick that like i
said before so we don't have
two different color material palettes
working against this
in a new construction so clicking ok
there and
going into new elements and
overriding that we'll see all of our
elements
have changed now one thing i missed in
these graphic override rules
is the simple fact that the fill
background
is transparent we want our fill
background to be white
so that we can actually see it stand out
if i click ok again
you'll see all my objects go back to
white and they're very clear and very
visible if we were to go back to show
original you see they're really grayed
out they're hard to see it's hard to
differentiate
between the existing and the new so it's
critical that you change that and
override that so you can
clearly differentiate between the two
now i know personally in different
practices i've been with
they don't use black as their key new
material they actually come across to a
blue
because it stands out a lot better so if
we change out to blue
click ok we very very clearly know
what's blue
we very clearly know what's new and we
know what's existing
these two colors we don't find too much
value in in the current office i work
for
for the simple fact that our builders
always print in black and white so it is
more about line types and line
quality especially printer quality we
tend to offer people
the ability to print from our services
because we know the printing will be
much better and we're not going to have
to worry about them going oh the printer
was a bit shoddy
and the grays are really gray the blacks
are really great i have no idea what's
going on however if you do specifically
specify
print and color they will know very
clearly
what's new what's old and it's a
fantastic option to go with a blue as
opposed to a black
now i know we show sketch design
differently to how we show our design
development and how we show our working
drawings
so if for example you want to duplicate
your existing
let's just go duplicate let's and rename
this
completely zero seven uh
sketch design now we've created an exact
duplicate of all the settings of
existing
but what i want to do is go into graphic
overrides go to existing
and change all of this to black so i
could change that to black
go override go back into these graphic
override rules
change the fill type change the
foreground pen
change the background pan change the
line type
go okay and all our walls are black
so it really is that simple to change
and adjust elements as you need as you
see
fit to really make it work for your
business your company
and whatever project you're working on
now i can simply click ok
we've done a whole bunch of changes
we've messed with it completely it's
very different to how we started
if you didn't follow along and change
all those settings exactly how i did it
that's okay this is youtube you can go
back and watch it a million times
but in reality all i really wanted to
show you is
how much of a difference it makes to the
actual drawings and design
so we've got existing we've got our
demolition we've got our after
construction
we've got our new construction and we've
got our sketch design
now if we were to do that same
experiment there in 3d
if we open up our three boxes we see
three simple gray boxes with no filters
applied
existing one of our boxes disappears
fantastic we don't want to see that new
construction so i'll spin back around
so it's in the same order it was in 2d
go into demolition
that box goes entirely red and we know
what we're knocking out
after demolition that box is gone we
have no idea it exists anymore
exactly like it would be on site new
construction
a beautiful box appears out of nowhere
now if we went back into our renovation
layers
went graphic override rules went to new
construction
and made sure that our new
looked purple we wanted to look purple
for some reason clicking okay
and okay our box is purple everything we
select
is simply changed like that so if i was
to just change
this one individual to new it would go
purple individually so if i went back to
existing
that wall would be completely missing
and we'd have no idea it ever existed
until we changed our settings to new
construction
layers the same principle applies for
demolition let's knock that out it's
gone you can't see it in new
construction
if we move back to existing it's there
again and then
same principle moved to demolition it's
red we know we're knocking it out we
know
what we're doing and finally i'm just
going to go back to no filters applied
to simply showcase the ease and ability
of
renovation filters by clicking through
some
tabs basically we're changing our entire
model
in a matter of seconds if you're not
using renovation filters
man you have been missing out for so
long because this makes life
so easy i truly hope this was a great
help to anybody that watched
if you have any more questions let me
know anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you learned something today about
renovation filters and arcade 24.
if there's anything left unanswered
leave a comment down below i check these
comments quite regularly and if you
really want to get in touch with me and
learn more there's a discord link
down below as well that you can join
discord chat together in an ever-growing
community of architects architecture
students and everybody else in the
discipline
we're slowly building our own little
discord world where we can all share
knowledge and get better
if that's something that interests you
there is a link down below if it's not
as always i will see you next monday